when we're not really feeling well is
that a physical problem or is it an
emotional chemical problem
well when it turns out that less than
ten percent of disease in fact maybe
even closer to one percent of disease is
actually connected to our genetics and
our physiology we have to say then where
is our illness coming from and the
answer is not from the mechanism but
from the consciousness that is driving
that mechanism and this is the relevance
of the new science of epigenetics versus
the old belief called genetics they both
sound the same genetics epigenetics but
there's a revolution and what's the
difference
the belief in genetics is that when i
say this issue this illness or whatever
it is is under genetic control is the
belief that genes are actually
manifesting the problem now there's an
issue about that as far as we know we
didn't pick the genes we came with if we
don't like the characteristics we have
can't change the genes and then we're
also told that genes turn on and off by
themselves
if you put all that together you're
recognizing you're not in charge of your
life your genes are controlling your
life well that's the old belief
because the new science is called
epigenetics and it sounds the same but
that epi is a revolution for this reason
epi means above
so for example what do we call skin
epidermis i said what does it mean the
layer above the dermis epi above so i
say then what is epigenetic control
means
it simply translates as this control
above the genes
what control is that
consciousness
your perception of your world is what
controls your genes and if you're not
feeling well
the issue is you don't have to change
your biology you just have to change
your perception
and this will then give you your power
back and this is what we have to
recognize we're not victims of biology
we are masters of our biology want to be
happy build a life not just the business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
you've got something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn the healthy
habits that will change your life
enjoy
habit number two is sleep better with
matthew walker you make a very powerful
case why sleep is the foundational
pillar of health
i used to think that sleep may be
the third pillar of good health
alongside diet and exercise
but the more i sort of did my research
and the more i read from other people i
realized i was probably wrong that in
fact sleep is the foundation on which
those two other things sit
and i'll give you an example in each
firstly for diet and exercise we know
that if people are trying to lose weight
and they're being judicious about their
food intake they're trying to
diet but they're not getting sufficient
sleep 70 percent of all the weight that
they lose will come from lean muscle
mass and not fat
because your body becomes very stingy in
giving up its fat when you are under
slept so dieting becomes you know quite
redundant in that regard you know you
you want to keep the muscle you want to
let go of the fat and sleep deprivation
will do the opposite to you so that's
the first thing it's a foundation
element on which you know nutrition sits
we know that um without sufficient sleep
two critical appetite hormones go in
opposite bad directions
one of those hormones is called leptin
which is a hormone that sort of signals
to your body you're full you're you
don't want to eat anymore the other
hormone is called ghrelin which does the
opposite it says you're not satisfied
with your food you want to eat more
um and despite leptin and ghrelin
sounding like two hobbits they are
actually real
hormones
what's interesting is that when you
sleep deprive people or even just limit
them to maybe just like five or six
hours of sleep for a week
levels of leptin which say you're full
don't eat more they drop down
levels of ghrelin that ramp up your
hunger and say i've just eaten a big
meal but i'm not satisfied i want to eat
more
that hormone skyrockets when you're
underslept so no wonder people who are
sleeping just five to six hours a night
will actually eat on average somewhere
between two to three hundred extra
calories every single day let me move
over to activity we've spoken about the
foundation on which diet sits
when you are not sleeping sufficient
amounts firstly the likelihood that you
will actually exercise decreases
significantly your motivation to be
physically active drops away
even if you are physically active the
intensity of your workout will not be as
strong so it's less effective and less
efficient
your things like your vertical jump
height your muscle contraction strength
even the exchange of carbon dioxide and
oxygen in your respiratory systems
they get worse when you haven't slept
what's even more frightening however is
that your risk for injury increases when
you are exercising but not well slept
this is incredible so there is yet
another demonstration of how even if
you're trying to be physically active
but not getting sufficient sleep it can
be harmful the beauty of that part of
the relationship and the same for diet
is that it's bi-directional that if you
actually you know improve your sleep
you can improve those two things but
conversely those two things will improve
sleep so if you start to correct your
diet you start to sleep better but
physical activity is a great way to
enhance both the quality and the
quantity of your deep sleep you know i i
often say this when i'm teaching doctors
you know why are we not bringing up
sleep quality
with pretty much every single patient
that walks in through our door sleep
really is the tide that raises all of
the other health boat it's the
superordinate node that if you
manipulate it you know it's like the
archimedes lever you pull that
everything else you know can start to
come into place you get the sleep but it
affects your brain affects your hormones
it affects your genetic expression it
affects
all these sort of things that we might
be looking for drugs to
to affect those individual pathways but
you can improve a lot of them by leaving
your sleep yeah you know and it's no we
think well that sounds almost too good
but don't forget you know it took mother
nature 3.6 million years to evolve this
necessity of eight hours of sleep in
place which i should note by the way
that if you look at the data
back in the 1940s the average adult was
sleeping about 7.9 hours of sleep now
that number here in the united kingdom
is closer to 6 hours and 30 minutes in
other words within the space of 100
years which is a blink of an
evolutionary eye we've lopped off almost
20 percent of our sleep need you know
how could that not come with
demonstrable health and disease
consequence
and all it takes is one hour of lost
sleep because there is a global
experiment that's performed on 1.6
billion people across 70 countries twice
a year and it's called daylight savings
time
and it turns out that when you look at
that data in the spring when we lose an
hour of sleep we see a subsequent 24
increase in heart attacks as a result
it's just incredible but in the autumn
you know when we gain an hour of sleep
we see a 21 reduction
in heart attacks so so the date is there
on a global level
it's striking you know and you can even
think you know you speak a lot about um
you know the immune system it's so key
for our health
if you look at people who become
infected or you actually infect them in
the experimental laboratory let's say
with sort of a cold uh vaccine
you immediately trigger
increased sleepiness and increased
amounts of deep sleep and it turns out
that the infection
indicates to the immune system that
you're under attack
and the immune system will actually
signal to the sleep system within the
brain
we need more sleep sleep is the best
battle force that we have right now to
combat this assault
and so that's why when you're sick all
you tend to want to do is just curl up
in bed and go to sleep the reason is
because your body is trying to sleep you
well that's an appropriate response to
what's going on exactly it's bodies are
pretty clever right they are remarkably
clever you know
again mother nature has figured this out
and so she brings up this thing called
sleep which i would argue is probably
like the swiss army knife of health you
know whatever ailment you are facing it
is more than likely that sleep has a
tool in the box to try and help fight it
that's so key whatever ailment you're
facing guys if you listen to this
whatever you're suffering from whether
it's you know lack of energy on a
day-to-day basis whether it's that
you're worried about your risk
of developing a chronic disease such as
type 2 diabetes or heart problems as you
get older
you know what matthew is saying what
professor walker is saying is that
sleep improving your quality of sleep
is going to help you
with all these different facets it's
going to help reduce your risk it's
going to help increase your energy it's
also going to reduce your risk
of actually
getting disease in the future which is
just absolutely incredible from
everything i can tell sleep is perhaps
one of the most democratic freely
available efficacious forms of
um of health insurance that you could
ever wish for what are those common
things that people aren't doing that
they could do to help improve their
sleep the first is regularity
going to bed at the same time and waking
up at the same time no matter what even
if you've had a bad night of sleep
still try to wake up at the same time
the second thing is temperature keep
your bedroom cool
and probably around about 18 degrees
celsius which is colder than most people
think
but cooling the room down takes your
body into that right sort of thermal
space for good sleep it cools it down we
are i think a dark deprived society in
this modern era and you need darkness at
night to allow the release of a hormone
called melatonin which helps time the
healthy onset of your sleep
so yes it's to do with blue light sort
of emitting devices screens phones those
are things that you should try and stay
away from in the last hour before bed
but it's not just that it's also
overhead lighting
you know we don't need to be bathed in
electric light all night in the last
hour before bed just try turning half of
the lights off in your flat or in your
home you'd be surprised at how soporific
and sleepy you become when you're
shrouded in darkness
so that's the third thing the fourth
thing is i would say walk it out
and what i mean by that is
don't stay in bed if you've been awake
for 20 or 25 minutes either trying to
fall asleep or you've woken up and
you're trying to get back to sleep
the reason is because your brain is this
wonderfully associative device and it
will start to very quickly learn that
being in bed is about being awake rather
than asleep so what you need to do
is after about 25 minutes just relax
understand that sleep is not quite here
yet go to a different room in dim light
read a book or listen to a podcast only
return to bed when you are very sleepy
and that way your brain will start to
relearn the association that your
bedroom is the place of sleep let's go
into caffeine i mean how much of a sleep
disrupter is caffeine if you have a cup
of coffee at noon
a quarter of that caffeine is still
circulating around your brain at
midnight
so to put that in context it would be
the equivalent of
getting into bed and just before you
turn the light out you swig a quarter of
a cup of starbucks and you hope for a
good night of sleep it you know you
would never do that because you know but
that's exactly unfortunately what people
do you know um completely innocently by
drinking caffeine you know still too
late in the afternoon habit number three
exercise with david promatter physical
exercise
changes your gene expression you were
able to change the expression of this
previously thought to be immutable life
code for the better and lead to the
expression of what we call a
trophic hormone or growth hormone for
the brain bdnf
brain derived neurotrophic factor
there are many things you could do to
amp up bdnf you can use
turmeric in your cooking take a dha
supplement
even cbd has been demonstrated recently
to increase
bdnf but the most important thing you
need to buy
to improve your bdnf is a new pair of
running shoes because aerobic exercise
is able to manipulate the expression of
his bdnf why specifically aerobic well
to a lesser degree
resistance exercise as well but i'm
simply telling people
20 minutes a day five days a week
hopefully more
at a heart rate value of 180 minus your
age as a target of course consult your
healthcare practitioner
but what a powerful way
to reduce your risk for dementia how can
i connect those dots and make that
statement to you as we sit here well the
journal of the american medical
association has wonderfully correlated
baseline bdnf levels with
future risk for dementia you want to
have more of this chemical that does two
important things
it increases the growth of new brain
cells in your brain's memory center
which is a powerful target for
alzheimer's okay and it also increases
the connection of brain cells one to the
other a process called
neuroplasticity that we can
actually
allow our brains to take advantage of
the experiences that we then choose to
pursue
to build a better brain and that is is
the bdnf a building block of that or no
it is not it's a signaling model it is a
signaling molecule i mean our brain
cells want to connect to each other and
our lifestyle choices that are highly
stressful that are deprived of
restorative sleep that are higher in
sugar in terms of diet
that are overall stressful uh increase
cortisol for example that inhibits the
growth of new brain cells actually
compromises
our brain cell population in the very
areas that we need them most like the
memory center the hippocampus so we can
we can reverse that we can tip the
scales in our favor and say i'm not
going to continue losing brain cells i'm
actually going to repopulate my memory
center with new brain cells that study
was done
out here at
ucla in collaboration with researchers
at university of pittsburgh led by a dr
erickson demonstrating two groups of
people
a hundred people in each group one group
stretched for a period of a year the
other group was involved in aerobics
they found that those who stretched had
lower levels of bdnf declining memory
function and shrinkage on very
sophisticated brain scans in terms of
their hippocampus size
which is the let's pause there because i
want to walk through this and make sure
that i understand
yeah this is incredible and potentially
very useful but i want to make sure that
i understand the sequence of events
right okay so first of all does bdnf
trigger the regrowth of brain cells
across the brain or just the hippocampus
good point we used to say the brain
doesn't grow do brain cells end the
story right i mean uh you're probably
too young to know that that's what i was
taught when i was in medical school we
were told that um
your brain grew maxes out at about age
18 then every beer you drink after that
it's 40 000 brain cells or whatever the
magic number was for whatever reason i
don't remember that but
um
how incredible
that
uh in your 90s you're still growing new
brain cells you have this gift
of regrowth of neurogenesis it's a
choice you can make
you can make it today after watching
this podcast by dragging those sneakers
out and
if only going to the mailbox is as far
as you can go then have at it tomorrow
you'll do that twice and the sequence is
you're doing the exercise the exercise
is creating bdnf bdnf is then triggering
hippocampal cell growth
yes but beyond that another area too
called the subventricular layer of the
what's called the ependyma in
the layer of cells that underlies those
fluid-filled compartments that you see
when you look at a brain scan but for
our purposes
the
synaptoplasticity and the
neuroplasticity the connection of brain
cells happens throughout the brain um we
also depend on a process called synaptic
pruning what does that mean
uh it means that also for brain function
we have to have the ability
as we are in our
childhood and adolescence to cut back on
the number of connections that we have
uh in order to kind of refine the the
computer to make it work at its optimal
level so which it's doing i'm assuming
based on repetition what you do the most
is going to get the most connections
it's going to get the most the highest
degree of insulation exactly all of that
neurons that fire together will wire
together and those that don't will
atrophy will fall off the tree also to
make sure you're actually taking action
after watching this video
i've designed a special free worksheet
just for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there habit number four breathe through
your nose with james nestor one of the
things that i am still perplexed by how
important it seems to be is breathing
through the nose um i would classify
myself as a chronic mouth breather i
catch myself doing it all the time uh
i
i want to know why does it matter so
much
and what are the benefits if somebody
were to
go to lengths to train themselves to
breathe almost exclusively through the
nose
so if you were to cut my head in half
and i've done this with it with a cat
scan and gotten a deli slicer view of my
whole head
you're going to see that the nose here
and the sinus passages take up about the
volume of a billiard ball sometimes even
more than that so this is an incredibly
ornate and complex organ that looks so
much like a seashell they call it the
nasal concha so sea shells they use
their shells the organisms within there
to keep out pathogens and to filter
stuff out that's exactly what our noses
do so air doesn't just shoot in into our
nose into our throat we have to force it
through this gauntlet of turbinates
and mucosa and cilia and all of these
different structures and while air is
being pressurized and forced through
this labyrinth it is moistened
it's heated
it's filtered
it's pressurized and it's conditioned so
that by the time it enters our lungs
we can better absorb that oxygen so just
breathing equivalent breaths
through the nose then through the mouth
will increase oxygenation about 20
percent
with each breath
so that's caused by a number of things
also nitric oxide uh i'm sure a lot of
your listeners know about nitro this
wondrous molecule that does
uh is implicated with uh with
vasodilation
it helps with gas exchange it's
essential we make six times more
no when we breathe through our nose and
if we hum
we make 15 for fold more nitric oxide
nitric oxide is also
uh some people may be interested in
knowing this that what does viagra do it
stimulates the release of nitric oxide
in our bodies creates vasodilation
uh you know where so we can we can do
this in our in our noses as well how
about number five eat right with william
lee to look for a way to prevent
angiogenesis in cancer i went back to
look at cancer's causes
and what really intrigued me was when i
saw that
diet accounts for 30 to 35 percent of
environmentally caused cancers
now the obvious thing is to think about
what we could remove from our diet what
to strip out take away
but i actually took a completely
opposite approach it began asking what
could we be adding to our diet that's
naturally antiandrogenic that could
boost the body's defense system and beat
back those blood vessels that are
feeding cancers
in other words can we eat to starve
cancer
well the answer is yes and i'm going to
show you how
and our search for this has taken us to
the market the farm into the spice
cabinet because what we've discovered is
that mother nature has laced a large
number of foods and beverages and herbs
with naturally occurring inhibitors of
angiogenesis
so here's a test system we developed at
the center is a ring from which hundreds
of blood vessels are growing out in a
starburst fashion and we can use this
system to test dietary factors at
concentrations that are attainable by
eating
so let me show you what happens when we
put in an extract from red grapes the
active ingredients resveratrol it's also
found in red wine
this inhibits abnormal angiogenesis by
60 percent
here's what happens when we add an
extract from strawberries
it potently inhibits androgenesis
an extract from
soybeans and here is a growing list of
our anti-angiogenic foods and beverages
that we're interested in studying
and for each food type
we believe that there's different
potencies within different strains and
varietals and we want to measure this
because well while you're eating a
strawberry or drinking tea why not
select the one that's most potent for
preventing cancer
so here are four different teas that
we've tested they're all common ones
chinese jasmine japanese sencha earl
grey and a special blend that we
prepared
and you can see clearly that the teas
vary in their potency from less potent
to more potent
but what's very cool is when we actually
combine the two less potent t's together
the combination the blend is more potent
than either one alone
this means there's food synergy
here's some more data from our testing
now in the lab we can simulate tumor
angiogenesis represented here in a black
bar
and using this system we can test the
potency of cancer drugs so the shorter
the bar less angiogenesis that's good
and here are some common drugs that have
been associated with reducing the risk
of cancer in people
statins non-steroidal anti-inflammatory
drugs and a few others
they inhibit androgenesis too
and here are the dietary factors going
head to head against these drugs
you can see they clearly hold their own
and in some cases they're more potent
than the actual drugs
soy parsley garlic grapes berries
i could go home and cook a tasty meal
using these ingredients
so imagine if we could create the
world's first rating system in which we
could score foods according to their
anti-androgenic cancer preventative
properties and that's what we're doing
right now
now i've shown you a bunch of lab data
and so the real question is what is the
evidence in people
that eating certain foods can reduce
androgenesis in cancer
well the best example i know is a study
of 79 000 men followed over 20 years
in which it was found that men who
consumed cooked tomatoes two to three
times a week had up to a 50 percent
reduction in their risk of developing
prostate cancer
now we know that tomatoes are a good
source of lycopene and lycopene is
anti-androgenic
but what's even more interesting from
this study is that in those men who did
develop prostate cancer those who ate
more servings of tomato sauce actually
had fewer blood vessels feeding their
cancer
so this human study is a prime example
of how anti-androgenic substances
present in food and consumed in
practical levels can impact on cancer
and we're now studying the role of a
healthy diet with dean ornish at ucsf
and tufts university on the role of this
healthy diet on markers of angiogenesis
that we can find in the
bloodstream now obviously what i've
shared with you has some far-ranging
implications even beyond cancer research
because if we're right it could impact
on consumer education food services
public health and even the insurance
industry
and in fact some insurance companies are
already beginning to think along these
lines check out this ad from blue cross
blue shield of minnesota
and for many people around the world
dietary cancer prevention may be the
only practical solution because not
everybody can afford expensive end-stage
cancer treatments but everybody could
benefit from a healthy diet based on
local sustainable anti-angiogenic crops
now
finally i've talked to you about food
and i've talked to you about cancer so
there's just one more disease that i
have to tell you about and that's
obesity
because
turns out that adipose tissue fat is
highly angiogenesis dependent and like a
tumor fat grows when blood vessels grow
so the question is can we shrink fat by
cutting off its blood supply
so the top curve shows the body weight
of a genetically obese mouse
that
eats non-stop until it turns fat like
this furry tennis ball
and the bottom curve is the weight of a
normal mouse if you take the obese mouse
and give it an angiogenesis inhibitor it
loses weight stop the treatment gains
the weight back restart the treatment
loses the weight again stop the
treatment gains weight back and in fact
you can cycle the weight up and down
simply by inhibiting androgenesis
so this approach that we're taking for
cancer prevention may also have an
application for obesity
the really truly interesting thing about
this is that we can't take these obese
mice and make them lose more weight than
what the normal mouse's weight is
supposed to be
in other words we can't create
supermodel mice
and this speaks to the role of
androgenesis in regulating healthy set
points
albertson georgie once said that
discovery consists of seeing what
everybody has seen and thinking what
nobody has thought
i hope i've convinced you that for
diseases like cancer obesity and other
conditions that there may be a great
power in attacking their common
denominator angiogenesis and that's what
i think the world needs now how about
number six is prevent problems with
peter medicine says
we don't do anything until there's a
problem
right so the entire system of the way a
diagnosis works the way a diagnosis is
attached to a set of symptoms the way it
is treated the way it is billed for and
the infrastructure of healthcare
delivery is all around waiting until
there is a problem treating that problem
and basically
you know doing better and better at
treating chronic disease and i don't
want to suggest that we have not done a
good job of that right so if you go back
in time 60 years
your likelihood of dying from your first
heart attack
was well over 50 percent
in other words you know somebody shows
up with a heart attack and by the way
for men two-thirds of those were going
to occur before the age of 65. wow so
you show up with your first heart attack
you know at that time you probably had a
70 80 chance of dying on first
presentation
well today thanks to
emergency medical care stents blood
thinners all sorts of other things we
have going you know lots of medications
that's no longer the case i mean we can
keep people alive for unbelievable
periods of time we have things like
dialysis we can do organ transplantation
we can
do so many things that do indeed extend
life in a chronic sense and i'm not
suggesting that we shouldn't do those
things it's just that when most of us
finish medical school we haven't got the
foggiest clue
on how you would tackle the problem the
way say david explained it
there's there's no system in place to
say that because if you really believe
in that system you have to figure out
how to prevent disease not treat disease
they're not the same thing and habit
number seven the last one before some
very special bonus clips is cleanse your
body with sad guru
i
have listened to you saying that 70 of
our body is water and
if we drink the energy water nearly
in our company so
could you please explain the should be
if you
tell your company i'm willing to work
without the air conditioner they would
be too glad
it would save them a lot of money
isn't it
and
it would be good for you in so many
ways but
but
now the city is not in that kind of
condition
where if you open your window breeze
will not come smoke will come
smell will come
dust will come
so
it's good convenient
but you don't have to sit here 24 hours
only for work
you can
take a walk whenever you can
and anyway 72 percent is water
12 is earth
only six percent is air in that six
percent air
air is not always in the breath out of
the six percent air that is here it is
only less than one percent which you're
breathing
rest is simply there
for some people it's concentrated in the
brain
but otherwise in every cell in the body
there is air
so when you say air it's not just the
breath
six percent air is in every cell in the
body
just remove it a little bit from the
brain it'll be good
it's good if it's in the lungs in the
heart and the muscles they function
better if there is oxygen you know
you know this if you're oxygen deprived
muscles become rigid
because this needs air otherwise it will
not work
so
water is 72 percent
so maximum care should be taken about
the water because it's 72 percent
if you are going to an examination
suppose
it is like this let's say you're going
for physics examination
you have water earth this that
but just the water subject is for 72
marks
naturally you spend more time
reading about water isn't it
studying water yes or no
air is only six percent
you may not study
because you are okay with 94
water you must study because it's 72
percent
you must take enormous care about the
water because it's 72 percent
and it has tremendous memory
if i
open this water even without opening if
i say something to this water it
remembers
there has been lot of experiments in
this direction
so
if you
take this water
from wherever the waterworks is and pump
it to your house
let's say it went through 50 bends
forced pumped forcefully with a certain
force which naturally is done and you
are living on 12th floor of the
apartment so further forced up
now they are saying if it goes through
50 bends about 60 percent of the water
has turned poisonous
immediately when it comes in the tap if
you take it and immediately drink it it
will work as poison in your system
if you take it and hold it for some time
it will undo itself again because the
poisoning is not chemical it is
molecular molecular changes are
happening no chemical change is
happening this is why traditionally your
grandmother always told you
always you must gather the water keep it
overnight in your house in a properly
cleaned vessel with vibhuti and kunkum
on it and one flower on it yes or no
traditional homes
only tomorrow morning you drink it
not as soon as it comes inside your
house you don't drink it because it
carries all kinds of memories
in very traditional homes
people every day do pooja to the water
pot
yes
and you never drink the water as soon as
it comes you keep it give it enough time
to undo itself from whatever nonsense it
is gathered so that it is suitable for
you when you drink it
water you must take care
because it's 72
it's more it's first class you know more
than passing mark
next thing is food
because that's the earth twelve percent
still substantial isn't it
so how food goes into you
from whose hands it comes to you
how you eat it
how you approach it
all these things are important
then comes your air six percent
in that six percent only one percent or
less
is your breath
rest is happening in so many other ways
and it's important especially if you
have children
at least once a month
take them out somewhere not to the damn
cinema
again breathing everybody's nonsense
the air gets affected just by the sounds
and the intentions and the emotions all
the rubbish that's happening on the
screen
and all the rubbish that's reflecting in
human minds
of violence of sex of the greed of this
and that
is affecting that limited air in that
hall in a tremendous way
so instead of taking them to the cinema
take them to the river
teach them how to swim
climb a mountain where is mountains with
guru himalayas is so far away
even a small hill is a mountain for your
boy
yes
even a little rock
just go climb and sit on one of them
children will enjoy it immensely they
will become fit you will become fit
and above all your body and mind will
function differently
and above all you are in touch with the
creator's creation which is the most
important thing
not your own rubbish that you made yes
it's comfortable right now but it's not
everything
so instead of going to the restaurant
instead of going to the cinema instead
of going somewhere else like that
at least once a month
it doesn't cost anything
huh
doesn't cost anything you can take your
rice and aokai and go and eat there
any way you have it
you don't have to spend money on this
even better
if you don't want to spend money even on
the bus or car
all of you cycle
just three kilometers five kilometers
outside
either a bird sit in one rock just spend
time there
feel the sun it's very important you get
some sun
air
good water
come back you are doing buddha
in a very natural way
it is not the ultimate type of buddha
shuddhi but you are doing some buddha
this is what i was saying just now if
you take care of food water
air is not always in your hands because
you're living in a city
but water and food you can take care and
what kind of fire burns within you
that also you can take care sunlight has
not become impure isn't it get some
sunlight every day please
get some sun on your body every day
because sunlight is still pure isn't it
nobody can fortunately contaminate it
and what kind of fire burns within you
is it the fire of greed
fire of hatred fire of resentment fire
of anger fire of love fire of compassion
what kind of fire burns within you you
take care of that then you don't worry
about your physical and mental
well-being it's taken care of
so i usually go to sleep around midnight
uh and i usually wake up around 7 30
7 7 30 somewhere in there
um that's a typical day it gets thrown
around every now and then but that's
that's kind of typical for me
okay so as an entrepreneur right with
like a crazy schedule because i know
you're such a schedule like you have
your set days on when you produce
episodes when you do your you know
public appearances right like with you
know blab and just go on other people's
podcast it's like how do you manage all
that and how do you manage to really get
enough sleep with all that crazy
schedule yeah and i have an added thing
where i have a really weak immune immune
system like if i don't sleep
seven hours consistently at least i get
sick
if i go two days in a row of bad sleep
i'm sick
uh i'm just it's you got a phone call
there bro yeah
it's supposed to be a mute
uh yeah i get sick like and for people
who've been watching my channel uh
there's a lot of videos where i'm sick
and uh it's often because of like either
lack of sleep or just you know at the
dance studio there's always lots of
people and you know you catch
viruses
um
so i need sleep if i if if i don't get
sleep one night the next night has to be
solid or i know i'm gonna be up so how
do you ensure that you get that you get
your seven hours in
yeah so a couple couple things i think
some of them are basics that you
probably heard before you know try to
keep to the same time uh try not to eat
like a heavy meal before going to sleep
because at least that keeps me up uh
i'm super sensitive to light so i i have
a mask on that that you know like if i
travel i forget my mask i'm having
terrible sleep um but some other things
that may be a little different than what
most people are doing um
one
we have no electronics in the bedroom
so there's no cell phone a bedroom
there's no ipad in the bedroom there's
there's nothing with a light you know
like if people stay up and read that
like blue screen and that just keeps you
awake and so our phones are plugged in
uh
outside the room and so my wife has an
alarm in the morning she's gonna get up
out of bed to go turn it off this is
nothing electronic in the room um so
that one helps because before we're kind
of sitting in bed next to each other
before we pass out and i think one it
also kind of gives you a little more
connection because there's
there's nothing to read so you talk to
yourself
talking to your wife before going to bed
but i think you know you get so
distracted by emails and news and stuff
so so no electronics in the room and
that's that's helped both of us i think
sleep um
two is
when i get an idea
i go and take care of it uh so i'll get
out of bed sometimes you go to bed with
with an idea like oh
you know i got a great idea for julian's
dance studio man and then and then you
lie in bed trying to forget it and and
you know wrestling with it and for me
it'll keep me up all night and uh
and then i'm going to worry that i'm
going to forget it because i don't have
a great memory if i don't write it down
it's gone and so i will get up and send
that email off to julian to tell him
about what he needs to do for his dane
studio uh or whoever it is and then it's
like it's released because otherwise it
stays with me and i have a terrible
sleep and so i'm not afraid to get up
and out to solve whatever is kind of
that that monkey in my head i need to
release it um
having a routine to help you wind down i
find super helpful so
just like you know when you're a kid you
have you have a routine that your
parents give you right like you have a
bath and you brush your teeth and you
get a bedtime story and like you get
used to that yeah
uh routine and then that helps you like
oh your body starts to shut down right
uh and then we kind of lose a lot of
that when we get
into adulthood and it's it's i used to
find it really hard like i come back
from my salsa studio after a great night
and i'd be wired like talking to people
and i just can't go to sleep right away
and so i need to create a schedule a
little routine to uh to decompress a
little bit today's challenge is to take
a cold shower and you're like i was
loving this guy until he said cold
shower i hate cold showers now why let
me talk about why because i don't like
cold period i don't like cold baths cold
showers cold environments but
cold could be your teacher many of you
listen to great avail to uh with great
response to our episode with wim hof i
met wim over six years ago wim hof is
the ice man if you haven't listened to
that episode please where he talks about
cold is my teacher where he climbs the
himalayas in his underwear and he swam
underneath the arctic amazing amazing
man but it talks about the power of cold
and if you listen to also my episode on
my morning routine you know one of the
things i do every morning is i take a
cold shower or an ice bath here so there
are a number of reasons why you want to
take a cold shower and starting with
number one it lowers inflammation it
lowers inflammation so one of the
challenges to your brain which also is
part of your body are high inflammation
levels and if you listen to our morning
routine we do things like have turmeric
turmeric tea and such which sounds
really good right after you take a cold
shower by the way cold reduces
inflammation it's like you you bang your
knee on a coffee table what do you do
you put ice on it to reduce swelling
inflammation but we also have
inflammation in our body so cold is very
powerful with that again listen to the
episode we did with wim hof the ice band
he's an expert at that because he lives
his talk he actually does it the second
reason why you want to take a cold
shower in the morning i don't go through
specifics on how long and such the
second reason is because it's like a
nervous system reset for me it's better
than coffee when i go into the cold i
feel like after when i come out of it
it's like i'm brand new and you can
attest to this have you ever gone into a
cold lake before or just like when you
go out in the cold you come in and
you're like you feel refreshed it helps
to reset your nervous system the third
reason why you do it though is because
you want to get yourself to do difficult
things especially as part of your
morning routine you get yourself to do
difficult things and that's what's
important here part of the reason we're
doing this quick brain challenge is we
know that challenge leads to real change
when you challenge yourself through
struggle your struggle by overcoming
that struggle becomes a strength or if
you will a superpower and so what are
you doing you're testing your ability to
be able to deal with what's
uncomfortable
and as we talk about if you're just
doing the easy things put things off
procrastinate then life is difficult if
you do the easy things life becomes
difficult but if you do the difficult
things you get yourself to do difficult
things you build your grit muscles if
you will then it's going to show up in a
life that becomes easier you know what i
mean like when you're doing difficult
things you have that difficult
conversation with somebody you get
yourself to work out you get all the
benefits of having an easier life
because life isn't is not necessarily
easier it's just you are better and so
when you're putting yourself in
uncomfortable situations like a cold
shower a cold bath some of you do a
cryotherapy where you're in a what is it
negative
230 degrees for two and a half minutes
obviously consult with your healthcare
practitioner you're putting yourself in
in a safe way in an uncomfortable
situation so you're building that
ability that fitness if you will to be
able to show up and speak in public if
you have a
fear of public speaking or to have that
meeting or to ask for that sale if
you're an entrepreneur or to do the
thing as a parent that you need to do
that you've been putting off so again
you're building your grit so again
reasons why you want to take a cold
shower number one lowers inflammation
number two it's like a big nervous
system reset which is great for your
brain and the third reason you're
training yourself first thing in the
morning to do difficult things so
there's a science to momentum you get
yourself to do difficult things and then
when you get to work doing that
difficult thing that you've been putting
off because i do believe that the
treasure you seek is found it's hidden
in the tasks you are avoiding so as
you're getting yourself in the habit of
creating new habits because that's what
we're doing with this challenge you're
going to do it today or tomorrow the
next time you take a shower now what
specifically are you doing
you want to build your way up to it i'm
not saying take a two-minute cold shower
because it's cold it's uncomfortable so
baby steps right every pro was once an
amateur and so every every every expert
was once a beginner so you go in and you
just do 10 seconds maybe you do 10
seconds on 10 seconds off and also their
health benefits going from cold to hot
if you've gone to some of the spas they
have a cold plunge and then like a
heated jacuzzi so it increases your
vascularity and so it's building that
pump if you will so go maybe 10 seconds
cold 10 seconds hot warmer 10 seconds
cold 10 seconds hot and you can build
yourself i do my box breathing my alpha
breathing my fire breathing my wim hof
breathing and i push myself in a healthy
safe way so do a little exercise with me
look around i'm going to test you find
everything you can see in this room
that's brown brown people brown clothing
brown things anything that's brown i'm
going to test you look around look
behind you don't miss anything close
your eyes
tell me everything you just saw that was
red
okay open your eyes and look for red
this time find red you got to find red
anywhere look for red look for red look
how many found a lot more red this time
and and didn't have it in your head
before raise your hand why because we
get what we
look for seek and ye shall find and i'll
prove it to you you'll even find things
that aren't there just to feel
successful i'll prove it to you you'll
find whatever you're looking for how
many saw beige stuff called it brown
just to feel successful let me see your
hands
how many saw burgundy called it red just
so you can succeed right so if you think
you're messed up you're gonna find
messed up stuff in yourself you'll color
it or someone else if you think you're
great you're gonna find great things so
if you want to free yourself i'm gonna
do a quick little meditation at the end
you've got to realize that we all suffer
at times and if you want to end
suffering
you have to make the most important
decision in your life which says i'm
going to live in a beautiful state
every day no matter what even when it
doesn't go my way even when there's
injustice even when people are unfair
because are people going to be unjust
and unfair in our lives yes or no and
are you going to be unjust unfair at
times without meaning to be yes or no
so if people have to behave a certain
way for us to be happy
you're not going to stay happy so let's
do
a two-minute meditation really fast now
it's not meditation like traditional not
think of something how many of you have
something in your life some unfinished
business that's stressful and so you put
it off you don't even try to think about
it it could be in your business it could
be in your personal life could be a
relationship how many got some at home
or at work that needs to be handled and
you put it off because you're so
stressed you got so much going on who's
got something like this
can you think of one specifically
awesome if you don't raise your hand
you'll lie about other things too but
that's okay we'll talk about later on
so here's what i want you to do on a
0-10 if you were to try to deal with
that right now honestly ten is totally
stressful zero's not at all
where is it tell me the number say it
out loud
how many got one seven or above of
stress if you focused on it perfect
because that'll help you change now i'm
gonna give you a quick technique for two
minutes they've got dozens and dozens of
these but it'll work for most of you
you'll see so here's what we found
research has been done
on how we get stressed and there's
something interesting they discovered
when you're born
your heart starts to beat that's birth
that's when you're alive i don't mean
born outside i mean inside the womb
there's no brain when your heart starts
to beat
what makes your heart beat
it has its own intelligence and it
affects your brain it affects your life
it affects everything when we get in our
head we're dead we over analyze we look
at things we get stressed out but in our
heart we know the answer so these
researchers did they were nominated for
a nobel prize because they found that if
you focus on your heart you put your
hands on your heart let's go ahead and
do it put your hands on your heart in
fact if you would would you stand up i
think it'll get more of your body engage
you've been sitting so long shake your
body out just for a second here just for
a second
if you're at home do the same right all
right now put both your hands on your
heart
breathe deep inside your heart meaning
close your eyes if you would
and feel your hands touching your heart
feel the power of your heart and what
we're going to do is for two minutes
we're just going to get grateful
remember earlier i said
you can't the two emotions that mess us
up are anger and fear they mess up your
relationships they mess up your
financial decisions they mess up career
stuff they may stop things with our kids
but when you're grateful you can't be
angry when you're grateful you can't be
fearful so we're gonna spend two minutes
of gratitude but we're gonna focus on
our heart because research shows
wherever focus goes energy flows and
when you focus on the heart it changes
literally how your brain functions i
could show you an image of when you're
frustrated and you'll see eeg's ekgs
that's the electrical power in your
brain in your heart and they're jagged
they're all over we'll probably put it
on the screen when they cut this but if
you breathe in your heart for two
minutes focusing on three things you're
grateful for they literally become in
sync they round and they're one and when
they're one your heart has the answer so
breathe deep in your heart and let's
begin
as you breathe deep in your heart feel
the power of your heart
feel the strength of your heart
feel the beauty of your heart what are
you proud your heart has guided you to
do with this in this life
or to give
or to enjoy
or to love
feel the power of your heart it beats a
hundred thousand times a day and you
don't have to do it you don't have to do
anything
in fact something loved you enough to
give you this heart
at the very beginning you didn't have to
earn it did you you didn't have to prove
yourself you didn't have to prove your
worth something knows your worth and
gave you this gift you can call god the
universe whatever you call it but feel
that powerful heart that beats and is
always there for you and has been for
decades
and give thanks for it
and as you're breathing in the sense of
appreciation and gratitude
we're going to take about a minute and a
half and focus on three moments in your
life you could feel deeply grateful for
they could be any three moments it could
be from your childhood it could be from
today it could have been from 10 months
ago
any moment that you could step back in
that memory as if you were there and
fill up with a sense of gratitude
so right now i'd like you to think of
one of those moments
a magic moment a beautiful moment from
any stage of your life what's been one
of the most beautiful moments of your
life yes
so breathe deep
breathe in your heart
and step into that moment that you
cherish
and fill up with appreciation with
gratitude
with joy and feel yourself going into a
beautiful state
as you breathe in your heart and feel
like you're there
think of a second moment now that you
could feel deeply grateful for
again it could have been any stage it
could be something little or big
step into that moment breathe like you
were breathing then
see what you were seeing then hear and
feel what you were hearing and feeling
then
and fill up with that feeling of
gratitude
of enjoyment
and then finally one more moment that
you could feel grateful for
that would be a really beautiful moment
in your life you could relive
step into that moment now
breathe deep into it see what you saw
hear what you heard feel what you felt
fill up
fill up with love or gratitude or joy
and if you can feel it it feels good
make a sound don't hesitate like a
little kid make a sound that feels good
to you just go make the sound
do it again
and one more time and make it even
louder
that's awesome now continue to feel your
heart and this gratitude i bet there
have been times in your life where
things happen for you that you didn't
make happen like a coincidence you went
to go do something you met somebody you
love or do something that led to a
career or a friendship
what's a coincidence you're grateful for
that led to something beautiful
and what if life was always happening
for you
not to you
what if you really believed that even
the pain was a gift because it got you
to grow or change or expand what if
everything was happening for you
and now you're in a really beautiful
state keep breathing in your heart and
then to finish this all you've got to do
is end this sentence for me keep
breathing in your heart not your head
your heart
feel up with that gratitude
and then ask yourself about that thing
that used to stress you a few minutes
ago
say all i need to remember
all you to focus on all i need to do in
that situation is what and trust your
heart and knows the answer that fast
feel your heart all i need to focus on
in that situation all i really need to
do
all i need to really appreciate or feel
or experience
all i need to focus on
all i need to believe all i need to do
is what
and your heart knows the answer raise
your right hand with your eyes closed if
you know the answer if you know exactly
what to do to resolve the situation
raise your right hand nice and high if
you would right now
and keep your hand up as soon as you got
it raise your hand
perfect keep your hand up
and then open your eyes and look at the
percentage of people who just in two
minutes have figured out how to solve
what was so stressful if you look around
it's about 90 percent
for those of you that are still there
you're kind of hanging on a little bit
and for those that are doing that there
are other techniques but did it reduce
it
yes even for those so for you ma'am you
didn't which one didn't raise your hand
one of you didn't raise your hand yeah
so did it reduce it for you so where was
it and where is it now
oh it went from a nine to a six so we
could do a second one it would stack it
so what i want you to do is this is a
way in two minutes you're starting to
feel stressed you breathe in your heart
you focus on what you're grateful three
things and then you look at the problem
and from your heart you solve it how
many got it let me switch your hands how
many got it like this give yourselves a
big hands beautiful experience people
have to make a decision what they want
to trade their life for yes because
every day we're trading our life
for the people that we associate with
for the business or job that we have you
know for what we eat for the health for
the enjoyment for the fun for the
experiences
and you have to ask yourself is my life
worth
trading
for that
if it's not
today is a good day to stop
i know that right yeah but most people
don't think that they're trading their
life
you know for something they think that
you know oh there's tomorrow and there's
next week really well
i have
you know evidence to prove otherwise
that we have no idea
you know when the last breath will be
yeah so let's trade our life every day
as it's the most important thing in the
world
and not from an ego perspective from uh
from a humble
grateful
perspective of wow
i get another day to live and to to
enjoy be grateful for that grateful for
that but then to respect it
see respecting your life means you're
going to trade it
for things that you feel
are worthy of it most people
you know ask themselves the wrong
question
they ask themselves you know am i worthy
of the goal and the dream that i have
and they should be asking themselves is
that goal that dream that i have worthy
of my life
changed the question
and if you say yeah i'll trade my life
for that good then go and do
that because you made it this far in a
video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to learn
the five habits that will improve your
health check the video right there next
to me i think you'll love it continue to
believe and i'll see you there they said
the blueprints of life you know all
diseases are created from genes
turns out less than five percent more
like one percent of people on the planet
are born with a genetic condition like
type 1 diabetes or